well now unthinkable that's the word
used by one of brussels former top
bureaucrats about the idea of a second
referendum on britain's membership of
the european union it's after some
high-profile campaigners had suggested
that voting out could strengthen the
UK's negotiating position that man is of
course josei manuel barroso who was
president of the european commission
until just over a year ago and he joined
me from princeton university in the
united states and i started by asking
him if he thought the prime minister had
negotiated a good deal for the UK i
really think he got a good deal I mean
it was difficult we have to understand
that there are 28 countries in Europe
unions and so it's not so easy to find
the consensus and in fact what David
Cameron was asking for was a complete
exception exception for the general
rules including something that has to do
it very important principle of freedom
of movement and the principle of
non-discrimination so everything is in
mind I really believe it was a good deal
and now of course I hope that it will be
supported by the British people now that
you're following the arguments in the UK
and one of the main ones at the moment
is about whether the deal will actually
be legally binding because there is no
treaty change involved no but there is a
commitment to make it really change and
so it will be legally binding I don't
know details of debate in Britain but
one thing I know I know well all your
opinion and what works and if there is a
commitment the commitment will be
respected by all the other member states
and also another discussion that somehow
if Britain were if the British people
were to vote to leave that there might
be room for more negotiation and then
perhaps a second referendum frankly I
don't believe that can happen that will
be really i mean unthinkable I'll say
it's practically impossible there was a
very tough negotiation as you know I was
in fact saying that before the summit
there will be drama there will be a
tough negotiation but at the
and I hope there will be an agreement
the agreement was possible but it was
not easy to get now if Britain British
people now after the final word if they
want to remain they are most welcome but
if the British people wants to leave
your opinion we have to respect that and
I think it will be not also very let's
say fair to the yield to the voters to
try to change their mind afterwards with
something new so frankly it's now in the
hands of the British citizens to decide
if they want or not to remain in your
opinion so when Mr Cameron says that he
would invoke the next day article 50
which would in which then starts whole
process for Britain leaving the European
Union if there is a leave vote the other
27 members of the European Union would
would agree with that and encourage him
to do it too look I'm not frankly I'm
not in a position now to elaborate on
input tentacle scenarios what I know is
that there was an agreement between
Britain and all the other countries of
Europe and now there will be referendum
to say yes or no if Britain wants to
remain on oh and now about hypothetical
scenarios frankly I are not properly
peeps to answer to them what about the
idea and this was expressed by Donald
teach the President of the European
Council that he said he's really afraid
that it might lead might might appear a
very attractive model for some
politicians in Europe to achieve some
internal and very egotistical goals he
says in other words other countries
might have a go what Britain's done of
course that's really a danger in fact
it's already happening I've heard that
now the garyun government already
mentioned the possibility of a
referendum on the issue of refugees I
mean we have nothing and at least I have
nothing against direct democracy but
your opinion is not just one political
system one democracy its 28 democracies
that are constantly negotiating and as
you know if every time there is a tough
issue a member says I'm going to make a
referendum I want some exceptions I mean
it will not work because at the same
time that we have national democracies
it's an international permanent
international negotiation so I really
like to think that this British case is
exceptional indeed there is some
exceptionality already in the British
situation Britain as you know as a
permanent opt out from hero Brittany's
odd member of shame and so there is
indeed already now exceptional situation
and now after this agreement bruton god
let's say the confirmation of this
exceptional status inside your opinion
that was possible because the other
countries very much want Britain to
remain in the European Union but now if
we accept it as a kind of rule then the
so-called ill hope Allah character and
sometimes we say in Europe I mean then
you have not the possibility of the
world your opinion working properly and
i think it should be on everyone's
interested european union that is not
perfect but basically we are so
important to give us a peace and
prosperity that it works properly and we
know the strange that the European Union
is under with the eurozone crisis the
migration crisis of course would it be
further destabilized if Britain left of
course and not only the stabilization in
terms of institutions but also in more
fundamental geopolitical terms I think
Prime Minister Cameron is absolutely
right when he says the vote yes is a
matter of national security we are
facing in Europe very serious challenges
not only the East with a very assertive
and sometimes aggressive Russia we are
also facing instability in the very near
to very close to us in the Mediterranean
including the terrorist threat so Europe
without Britain will be weaker I know
someone who is going to be commemorating
that it will not only be some arrows
cappy's in Britain they will be together
with President Putin in Moscow because
everything is trying to do is to show
that Europe will be divided so in terms
of our overall stability and security
what is at stake is indeed very very
important by the way it's not by my
some absurd seeing that the Americans
here where i am now i'm now at Princeton
the Americans are asking the British
people to vote yes because for West in
general it will be certainly a defeat if
the European Union loses one of its most
important two members in lead one of
most important countries in the world
and if the UK does vote yes where do you
expect it as has been expressed by many
in the European Union that Britain would
then take a more active and central role
within the European Union yes and in
fact will during my 10 years in little
European Commission European Union and
I'd also be forest Prime Minister and
its foreign minister many years Britain
was living even with mrs. Thatcher she
was considered a neuro skeptic but
frankly mrs. Thatcher are extremely
important for the enlargement process
for the internal market deepening and so
on with Blair also for the climate
change talks it will be impossible for
the european i can tell you because I
was leading European Commission at that
time it will be impossible for European
isn't to agree on that such an ambitious
climate policy dog British leadership
and also David Clemen everything that
has to do with better regulation
simplifying regulation that owes a lot
to British leadership so I would like to
see but that's my personal opinion
Britain at the center of the European
Union and let me tell i'm coming from
porsche as you know but i think most
medium size or smaller countries in
europe would like to have that we look
like Trevor Europe without a family so
it is important that Germany the pulse
of France Britain another bigger
countries in Europe cooperate and that
they support this common let's say
enterprise we have Britain is one of the
biggest shareholders in your opinion and
it will be a pity I really believe for
for for all of us and I'll say also for
Britain eyes I hope I suppose that if we
we don't defend our own common good
together and lasting the super also you
mentioned the refugee crash
the migration crisis do you feel that
that might have an influence on the vote
in the UK which takes place in the early
summer if the British people see
hundreds of thousands more refugees
flooding into the European Union there
might be more tempted to vote to leave
I'm afraid it may have some impact yes
because wrongly it is associated with
your opinion when in fact it was not
your opinion that was creating these
difficulties and with our without
European Union wheel are without
Schengen we will have to face the
refugees crisis because they will come
to Europe they will try to come to our
countries so yes there is that risk and
the fact that we are now approaching
summer where more refugees cross
Mediterranean and more illegal migrants
try to reach our shores that may have an
impact that's why I i have to tell you
very frankly I'm concerned about what
can be the result of the referendum at
the end I'm sometimes considered and I'm
accused of being an Anglophile I very
much trust the common sense the wisdom
the pragmatism of the British people and
even those that don't love your opinion
I believe that they will be at the end
making a rational choice why should we
change now why should we put at risk
what we have or why should we make a
jump in the dark so I'm still confident
but I have to be honest I'm concerned
about the result of the next referendum
just a manuel barroso thank you so much
for your time we very much appreciate it
my pleasure thank you